[Música]
ruas e bairros
onde está o trem acima
Ele fala comigo ou volta, ele já estava com você
Eu não ganho duas derrotas, eles são todos amigos
Eles não estão preocupados com esse padrão e vêm com
minha palma não me protegeu saiu daqui
a magnitude chilena é muito
maneiras baratas
ela é minha mais velha
Porque
[Música]
não é mais
há muita estima yucca
[Aplausos]
sua
você não terá cicatrizes de ambiente quente
medir melhor o que eu sou muito pouco
nós, mito humano, uma hora sagrada
apreendido que ela era um meio-sangue
grande prêmio das mãos de sua falta de um
missão de fazer o mágico esquecer que
todas as estátuas loucas e francas sombras que
sair quando estiverem matriculados e não houver
vocação sustentada pela mesma pessoa minha
solidão
e eu cheguei, ele me deu um maio, você pode ver
que é verdade e que vamos
pequeno crédito de gatinho e minha navalha
algo difícil porque de Cádiz e banda dupla
tem gosto diferente
Eu gosto desse jeito quando eu vim com
todos nós aprendemos aquele
pessoa atinge o conjunto
2018 se você está fazendo
estou sofrendo uma benção
e com meus privilégios não gosto com um
O mundo vivo é recusado o melhor da Europa
de qualquer maneira, visite um estande
tensão máxima para um novo idioma
quando nada acontece no clube e pronto
quem estava com você não
[Música]
eles estão preocupados, mas sim
na minha província foi suicídio e
momento chileno de sofrimento por vivoratá
caminhos
[Música]
mais
linda você é minha machuca
[Aplausos]
viu
e eu te amo mais